well russia's invasion of ukraine has
surprised many military analysts who'd
expected fighting to be over very
quickly instead the three-month-old war
has exposed unexpected weaknesses in
russia's forces heavy troop and
equipment losses have reportedly hurt
morale even more and the war's initial
aims have been severely scaled back
it was supposed to be over in a few days
russian tanks rolled into ukraine from
multiple directions
from belarus in the north separatists
controlled parts of ukraine and russia
itself in the east and occupied crimea
in the south aiming to decapitate the
government by taking the capital kyiv
and capturing as much territory as
quickly as possible but planning and
logistics soon proved to be a major
problem
a menacing 40 kilometer line of tanks
and personnel carriers was spotted
heading towards kiev but it soon bogged
down and came under ferocious attack
russian tanks were cut off from fuel
supplies and abandoned
and the army gave up on kiev
in late march russia shifted its efforts
to the east trying to cut off a huge
chunk of territory south and east of
hakiv but it became clear that the
invading army had another problem
command and control
officers on the ground had to call
senior officials in moscow to make the
smallest decisions
meanwhile dug-in ukrainian forces
inflicted heavy losses on the russians
who made few gains
in fact around hakiv they lost
significant territory generals were
called to the front to solve problems
and several were killed in battle
images of a botched river crossing were
a major embarrassment
dozens of tanks destroyed and hundreds
of soldiers killed in what experts say
was a desperate attempt to show some
kind of progress
as russia's attempts to take new
territory were scaled back to a small
slice of the original aim of taking the
entire donbass region it became
increasingly clear that there was a
major problem with morale
intercepted communications showed
russian soldiers discussing sabotaging
their own equipment or trying to injure
themselves to be sent away from the
fighting
that makes it harder and harder to make
progress and even hold territory against
super motivated ukrainian fighters
the coming weeks will show if russia can
hold the territory it seized
or whether ukraine will push the
invaders
back to the border
let's bring in frank ledwig here he's
our regular military analyst he joins us
from oxford in the uk
frank this war is now entering its
fourth month moscow has suffered
multiple defeats and has had to scale
back its ambitions are you surprised by
how well the ukrainians have held the
russians back
terry we were all surprised in the early
days in the first month or so at the
degree to which conventionally the
ukrainians uh worked their work their
military magic as it were now less so
the last two and a half months or so
have demonstrated why that is we've just
heard on that report some of the reasons
essentially russia is operating a
peacetime army uh which is having
problems with manpower come back to that
in a minute
secondly of course and more importantly
ukraine is fully mobilized it's also
backed by very capable the world's most
capable by far military alliance so
that's from the physical perspective the
the material and kit conceptually rushes
all over the place from the start it
didn't have a central approach it didn't
have a main effort
and uh and it's had to scale that down
and furthermore it retains old command
structures and old ways of doing
military business ukrainians
particularly over the last eight years
have learned a great deal about how to
exercise command and control they
devolve command and control to the lower
levels finally and most importantly
terry is the moral component and that we
saw from uh max's report before partly
why that is ukraine is defending their
homeland against a vicious and brutal
enemy than they are
whereas the russian soldiers don't seem
to have much of an idea what they're
doing indeed russian leaders have no
strategic focus so from the physical the
conceptual and the moral perspectives
ukraine is a superior fighting force
russian forces are still trying to take
more territory in the donbass region
though
given russia's capabilities the lay of
the land there its proximity to russia
the separatist strongholds there is it
not just a matter of time frank before
the donbass region is fully under
russian control
two things from what you said there
terry very interesting first of all you
did mention the proximity of russia and
its main main main supply routes into
the combat zone and that's true there
are big bases at rostov in belgrade and
uh and indeed all across the russian
border so they've got short lines
communication which they didn't have in
the north that's true however concerning
the lay of the land yes parts of that
area are good for maneuver warfare which
would tend to to support the idea that
russians would be good at it but let's
not remember the center of this the
decisive battles are going to be fought
in liman sivero donetsk and possibly
leshansk those are urban areas and even
before we consider the deficiencies of
russia in the respects we mentioned
before
you would expect an attacker against a
city to have a five to one advantage
russians can leverage some of that with
artillery but they won't have that
advantage against prepared ukrainian
positions and as long as the west keep
up their supplies and reinforcements of
artillery and excellent kit ukrainians
should be able to hold it that said
president zolensky said yesterday this
is going to be a hard summer and it
certainly is
frank thank you very much for your
insights that was frank ludwig military
analyst in oxford
thank you terry
now let's look at some other stories uh
making news in the ukraine war ukrainian
president vladimir zelinsky has called
for maximum sanctions against russia and
said vladimir putin is the only russian
official he would meet to negotiate an
end to the war with
he spoke via video link to the world
economic forum in davos switzerland
russian business leaders are and
diplomats are barred from this year's
meeting
a senior russian diplomat has resigned
because he's against the invasion of
ukraine boris bondaret worked for
moscow's mission to the united nations
in geneva he's written to colleagues
saying he's ashamed of the war
and starbucks is pulling out of the
russian market the seattle coffee giant
has announced the closure of all its 130
stores there the brand had initially
said it would keep stores open but
donate profits to humanitarian relief
efforts in ukraine
mcdonald's exited the russian market
last week
three months into the ukraine war the
fighting has moved largely to the east
of the country there russia is making
slow progress in its attempt to control
the donbass region for now the center
and west of the country are no longer
threatened by russian artillery or war
planes but some towns outside of kiev
that saw devastating fighting are still
struggling to recover dw correspondent
max tanda visited the town of hostimel
where an international team of
psychologists are helping residents
process the wounds of war
a busy morning at the clinic in the kiev
suburb hostel
bullet holes in the windows bear witness
to the russian occupation medical staff
have been working round the clock since
the clinic reopened in april
they're dealing with visible and
invisible wounds
i think there's kind of a collective
trauma if you like with
people living in the communities
psychologist malcolm hugo has joined the
operation here as part of the
international organization doctors
without borders he just returned from a
home visit in the area
the woman
whose house was completely destroyed was
living there with her son
who's uh 30 years of age and
and unfortunately he was killed
in their driveway by a a rocket
so she's obviously going through a
grieving process she's on her own now
the key of suburbs bore the brunt of the
fighting in the early days of the
invasion that was followed by a ruthless
occupation marked by violence against
residents
the russians have left reconstruction is
underway but people here are only
starting to put their lives back
together
the emotional scars run deep
there are various types of trauma people
here are dealing with like those who
experience the occupation and extreme
levels of violence
than others returning to their homes
seeing not much left of it
and then there are those who are taken
prisoner by the enemy kidnapped and even
taken across the border
oleg is one of them
he says russian soldiers shot him in
both legs in front of his home
then took him and his son
they dropped me on the porch and started
to put the gun to my head and in my
mouth
when my son saw this he got on his knees
and screamed please don't kill my dad
they put us in the vehicle blindfolded
up with tape
tied our hands and took us
in an unknown direction
they were taken across the border to
belarus
then flown to korsk in russia
weeks later oleg was freed in a prisoner
exchange his son
is still missing
it eats you from the inside and you
can't take away the sorrow with your
tears
we need distraction through work and
life while we're waiting for his fridge
there are believed to be hundreds of
similar cases in this town alone
oleg has joined the team of doctors
without borders seeking to assist the
psychologists by sharing his experiences
doing his bit to help others heal
and our correspondent max sander who
filed that report joins me now from
ukraine's capital kia max we saw an
extreme example of psychological trauma
in that report but countless ukrainians
are dealing with their own personal
trauma in this war how are people coping
there generally
well that's right terry so the people
living in that area in the suburbs of
kiev a lot of them have really extreme
experienced extreme cases of of trauma
some of them were witnessed or
experienced
pillaging uh
violence uh murder rape torture um so
people there are going through a lot
collectively
from talking to these people it seems
that it's
um
important for them to keep busy to to to
work to focus on their family to to
put their lives back together and
reconstruct their lives and even
reconstruct their homes in many cases
now the psychologist that i i spoke to
in that report he also said one thing
that that stuck with me he said it was
amazing
about the he said the resilience that
some people displayed in dealing with
these situations i'm really amazed him
but that being said it's still very
important that you don't just pack away
your emotions but try to seek
psychological help and try to deal with
this on a professional level
but then there are so many cases in this
country everybody is affected in one way
or another not just in the suburbs of
kiev but uh in the occupied territories
close to the fighting line there are six
million people who fled the country or
who are internally displaced even in
this
somewhat seeming peaceful capital of
kiev at the moment people are dealing
with air raid alarms multiple times a
day so everybody has a story and is
dealing with this in one way or another
yesterday ukraine saw its first war
crimes trial and in a life sentence for
a russian soldier more trials are
expected what do these trials mean for
ukrainians max and for russians for that
matter
right so for the ukrainians this was the
this was the first war crimes trial and
uh
during and um
as a reason of this
uh invasion that's happening right now
um for the ukrainians it's it's a it's
an opportunity to uh to follow up on
their commitment and show that they're
going after these crimes the crimes and
they're pursuing them accordingly the
russians on the other side haven't
really
said much about this other than that
they were not able to provide
proper legal assistance
to their soldier there and they would
try to help him through other channels
now what exactly that means
we don't really know but there has been
some talk in the past that this very
prominent case that the soldier may be
part of a prison exchange in the future
and there also have been some concerns
of people following the trial that
this life sentence is very the
prominence of this case may have
implications on trials in russia held
against ukrainian pows
okay let's move on to the war itself max
what's happening in the battle force of
silver donetsk that city in the luhansk
region has been under heavy bombardment
by russian forces are ukrainian troops
holding on there
right ukrainian troops are holding on to
seville donetsk that is the case but the
russians are trying to to to get it to
encircle the town they've been trying to
take neighboring villages from there
continue on to uh the city itself
there's been heavy um heavy bombardment
of uh residential areas uh places in the
outskirts of the town we've heard from
the military administration that roughly
90 of the infrastructure is destroyed
there's only one um
there's only one
street going in and out and people are
not being able to be able to evacuate at
the moment due to the shelling
max thank you very much dw's max tunder
there in kiev
you